qui protégeait les régimes en place au
mali mais aussi au tchad la france ne se
retire pas un ni du mali du sahel s'agit
bien d'une transformation une
réorganisation ce ne sont plus les
militaires français forcément qu'ils
sont aux premières lignes ce sont les
militaires maliens au regard de la
situation actuelle il est clair que nous
avons fait l'essai il va falloir en
tirer les leçons et cesser de mettre sur
le compte de fée news une campagne d'
influence le ressenti est l'état
d'esprit des populations
si on ne veut pas se retrouver comme les
américains en afghanistan
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allen une réunion européenne d'urgence
sur l'élégant se déroulait ce dimanche à
calais elle s'est déroulée sans les
britanniques excluent par la vente l
objectif renforcer la lutte contre les
réseaux de passeurs après la mort
mercredi dernier au moins 27 personnes
dans le naufrage de leur bateau
pneumatique le pire drame grattoir
survenu dans la manche dans son ciel
sera déployée dès le 1er décembre un
avion front texte côté allemand demande
un accord urgent entre londres et
bruxelles son intégration
[Musique]
sur le front sanitaire l'inquiétude
grandit face à la propagation du nouveau
variant du coville omicron il arrive
tout droit de l'afrique du sud et il a
été identifié dans plusieurs pays en
europe l'allemagne le royaume uni et les
pays bas conséquence l'afrique australe
qui s'ouvre est tout juste au monde se
retrouve isolé de nombreux pays ferment
leurs frontières avec cette région on ne
sait pas si les vaccins du marché
résiste vraiment à cette nouvelle souche
[Musique]
comment désamorcer l'explosion de colère
aux antilles le ministre d outre mer va
tenter d'y répondre il est en route vers
la guadeloupe qui se pose maintenant la
question de l'autonomie direction
ensuite la martinique le calme est
revenu dans ce département en proie aux
violences sur fond de contestation
en terme d'obligation vaccinale pour les
soignants
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france un avion de
l'agencé européenne frontex déployés au
1er décembre dessus de la manche
décision prise lors d'une réunion
d'urgence sur les migrants à calais ce
dimanche elle s'est déroulée quatre
jours après la mort d'au moins 27
personnes dans le naufrage de leur
bateau pneumatique dans la manche le
pire drame jamais arrivé dans la mer
séparant la france du royaume uni
justement londres a été exclu du meeting
par paris sur fond de tensions entre les
deux parties à la france qui plaide en
faveur d'ailleurs collaboration tout de
même avec les britanniques aient quitté
gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur qui était présent à calais
cette réunion n'était pas anti anglaise
et était pro européenne et nous devons
travailler que nos amis britanniques et
leur dire à sa tombe deux choses d'abord
nous aider collectivement un mieux
lutter contre les passeurs nous l'avons
dit des renseignements nous manque des
réponses parfois ne sont pas toujours au
rendez-vous des demandes de la police
française par exemple j'ai longuement
parfois échangé avec mon homologue
britannique et nous devons travailler
sérieusement sur ces questions et nous
souhaitons travailler avec nos amis
britanniques en européens la france avec
la grande bretagne bien évidemment mais
ne fait dans un cadre sérieux et sans
être l'otage de politique intérieure et
sachez que l'allemagne a appelé à
l'adoption urgente d'un accord entre le
royaume uni à l'union européenne je vous
propose de regarder maintenant ces
réactions d'associations dead aux
migrants pas vraiment convaincu par les
pouvoirs publics
il faut absolument que les politiques se
réveille si rien ne change dans les
politiques qui sont menées partout en
europe et à la frontière ici on va
revivre ce drame cet hiver quand le
gouvernement accuse les passeurs c'est
une façon de masquer ses propres
responsabilités si la frontière
n'étaient pas bloqués et s'il y avait
des possibilités de passage légaux en
grande bretagne il n'y aurait pas de
passeurs ce que je crains c'est que la
réponse soit uniquement répressive et
sécuritaire que l'on continue de penser
que le problème ce sont les passeurs
alors que le problème ce sont les
politiques qui encourage et favorise les
réseaux de passeurs
l oms lance un appel pour que les
frontières restent ouvertes dans un
communiqué aujourd'hui plusieurs pays
ont fermé leurs frontières avec
l'afrique australe et en afrique du sud
que le nouveau variant micron a été
détectée pretoria qui demandent la levée
immédiate et urgente à des restrictions
de voyage et on a appris également ce
dimanche que le maroc a décidé de
suspendre tous ses vols vers son
territoire en cause la propagation
rapide de la souche dans le monde pays
bas allemagne ou encore au royaume uni
où de nouvelles restrictions vont entrer
en vigueur mardi après trois cas avérés
ont fait le point sur la situation avec
sébastien a pas il n'aura pas fallu
longtemps pour pousser l'état d'israël à
agir contre le variant omicron le
gouvernement a annoncé la fermeture de
ses frontières aux ressortissants
étrangers pour une prise d'effet ce
dimanche soir après la détection d'un
cas chez un voyageur revenant d'afrique
australe à présent nous devons resserrer
nos frontières afin de maintenir israël
ouvert à l'intérieur cela implique que
nous devrions changer de destination de
vacances et nous isoler au retour des
conséquences qui touche également ma
propre famille les restrictions aux
frontières du pays ne sont pas une tâche
facile mais constitue une étape
temporaire est nécessaire
en plus de l'état d'israël le maroc a
décidé cet après midi de suspendre tous
les vols directs de passagers à
destination de son territoire pour une
durée de deux semaines afin de freiner
la propagation du virus
la présidente de la commission
européenne ursula von der leyen a évoqué
une course contre la montre pour
analyser le nouveau variant omikron en
france on se prépare également à son
arrivée selon le ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand il serait même déjà aux
portes du pays dès qu'il ya un cas
suspect nous isolons la personne et nous
procédons à des tests poussés c'est à
dire un séquençage nous regardons le
profil génétique du du variant et du
virus à date il ya encore une
identification de ce type de varien au
micro sur le territoire national mais
c'est une question d'heure très
probablement il faut se dire les choses
ils circulent déjà en belgique il a été
identifié en italie il a été identifiée
en allemagne je voyais qu'il était
identifié également d'australie donc
il provient vraisemblablement de
l'afrique australe nous sommes en train
de travailler avec une coordination
internationale pour pouvoir identifier
tous les tenants et aboutissants parce
que nouveau variant de ne veut pas
forcément dire nouvelle vague ou que le
variant soit plus dangereux
manifestement s'il arrive à circuler à
faire sa place dans des pays dans
lesquels il ya déjà une vague de
vaillants delta qui est très contagieux
c'est que nous pouvons craindre que ce
variant nouveaux variants soit au moins
aussi contagieux que le delta ce qui
n'est pas évidemment une bonne nouvelle
si de nombreux pays sont sur le pied de
guerre en afrique du sud premier pays à
avoir alerté sur ce variant on temporise
la présidente de l'association des
médecins sud africains dénoncent des
réactions démesurées qui pourrait
impacter la coopération sanitaire entre
les pays
dancefloor les réactions précipitées en
particulier celle du royaume uni qui ont
suivi l'annoncé risque à l'avenir j'en
suis sûr de rendre les scientifiques et
les pays moins transparents et cela
pourrait mener à la catastrophe il ne
s'agit donc pas seulement de mes données
mais aussi de celles d'autres médecins
généralistes exerçant à pretoria et dans
les environs qui observe plus ou moins
la même chose que moi des symptômes très
très léger ce qui signifie que nous
pouvons facilement les traités à
domicile
jusqu'à présent à ma connaissance aucun
de mes collègues n'a eu à mettre un de
ses patients sous oxygène leur niveau
d'oxygène étant très très stable
selon des données préliminaires le
variant omicron détecté pour la première
fois en afrique australe au début du
mois de novembre serait plus contagieux
que le variant delta la version
actuellement dominantes du coronavirus
dans le monde plus difficiles à détecter
en raison de symptômes plus léger à
l'heure actuelle aucune étude n'a encore
établie précisément quel est son degré
de dangerosité alors que pretoria
regrette son isolement écouter ses
réactions en afrique du sud de voyageurs
bloqués sur place
je pense que ça n'a pas de sens ça ne
peut pas être fait si soudainement il
doit y avoir des stratégies à mettre en
oeuvre il faut le faire progressivement
je sais que c'est un virus et que ces
choses affecte les gens mais cela
affecte aussi les connais même pas fait
mieux connaître l
instant je pense que c'est un peu
exagéré
je sais qu'il y ait un nouveau variant
mais il n'y a pas beaucoup de cas pour
le moment donc je pense que pour
l'instant c'est contestable
c'est juste
m'en fiche ne pas en mourir si juste un
peu de retard
je préfère c'est avec le en fait on
ramène et un truc
au micron suscite beaucoup d'inquiétude
car on n'est pas sûr de l'efficacité des
vaccins sur cette nouvelle souche
mutante il faut encore attendre les
résultats des études sismiques ont surgi
il ne faut pas oublier que le variant
delta circule beaucoup plus comme nous
le rappelle gilbert à bejjani les
médecins anesthésistes et on écoute
vaccin a été fait à partir des premières
souches du commun et donc en effet on
est allé au micro il y en a eu d'autres
dont on n'a pas beaucoup parlé l'epsilon
liotta et l'état sont il ya déjà eu
beaucoup de variantes ils n'ont pas été
de grands intérêts donc en effet on est
l'actuel variant qui domine c'est le
delta qui est déjà la plus infectieux
est plus contagieux que la version de
base et s'ils se transmet plus il
prendra le dessus donc moi mon espoir
est le message que j'aimerais faire
passer ici c'est le vaccin jusqu'à
maintenant reste plus efficace que le
fait de ne pas être vaccinés même si ça
son efficacité diminue et il faut donc
deux choses aujourd'hui vacciner très
largement surtout dans les pays où la
vaccination n'est pas encore tout à fait
disponible pour tout le monde donc il
faut pas simplement
s'enfermer en europe et ne pas penser
aux restantes et il faudrait qui de nos
jours vaccin qui arrivent sur le marché
sont des vaccins qui sont adaptés à ces
nouveaux à ses nouveaux variants et ce
large à oui des suisses au passage coded
en pleine cinquième vague la loi
autorisant d'instaurer le pasco vide a
été largement approuvé lors d'un vote ce
dimanche marquées par une participation
très élevé au terme d'une campagne
électorale houleuse c'est l'un des rares
pays à avoir organisé un référendum sur
cette question une consultation sur fond
de manifestations contre les
restrictions sanitaires à l'instar de
nombreux pays européens le texte
plébiscité par les suisses restent bien
non cadres
et dans ce contexte d'une nouvelle vague
épidémique l'union européenne n'a
toujours pas validé les accents russes
et chinois lors d'un entretien hier dans
l'émission d'arte et internationale
world apart le ministre hongrois des
affaires étrangères a fustigé ce qu'il
considère comme une hypocrisie
occidentale selon lui ses positions
politiques vont à l'encontre de la santé
des citoyens européens on écoute
précédemment nous avons commencé à
utiliser spoutnik et le vaccin chinois
sinopharm notre régulateur national a
autorisé l'utilisation de ces deux
vaccins ce qui signifie que
l'utilisation de spoutnik en hongrie est
fondée sur la réglementation européenne
et donc pour être honnête nous ne
comprenait pas pourquoi d'autres états
membres de l'union européenne ne
respectent pas cette décision
pour eux c'est un sujet de discussions
politiques et idéologiques
pour être honnête cela me déçoit
énormément mais je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi la réglementation européenne
est très clair quant à la manière dont
un vaccin peut être approuvée sur le
territoire de l'ue eux il y à deux voies
possibles la première implique l'agencé
européenne des médicaments
c'est la façon d'isoler un standard
d'obtenir l'approbation d'un vaccin mais
la réglementation européenne stipule
qu'en cas d'urgence et c'est le cas les
régulateurs nationaux sont également
autorisées à accorder une approbation
temporaire au vaccin
le ministre a d autres maires en route
pour les antilles sébastien lecornu doit
tenter de pérenniser le retour au calme
en guadeloupe et en martinique après des
jours de contestation dupas sanitaires
et l'obligation vaccinale pour les
soignants dans ces départements les
mobilisations se poursuivent toujours
elles ont révélé une crise sociale
ancienne et profonde pour tenter
d'apaiser la situation à l'obligation
vaccinale de soignants a été repoussée
et le gouvernement se dit prête à ouvrir
le débat sensible sur une plus large
autonomie de la guadeloupe on va
justement écoutez à ce propos arnaud
benedetti les rédacteurs en chef un
revue politique et parlementaire
derrière le refus finalement de la
validation d'une partie de la population
en guadeloupe et en martinique nous
demeurons également de la vaccination il
ay ay plie de défiance on peut les
antilles et la mecque la métropole qui
est ancienne qui est liée notamment à
des disparités des disparités sociales
économiques je rappelle que plus d'un
tiers des jeunes sont au chômage en
guadeloupe ce que on est largement au
dessus du seuil de porter deux
parties la catégorie grande partie de la
population il y a en effet une défiance
qui est très forte et pourquoi avoir
repris et mis autant de temps c'est
qu'en fait que l'exécutif a d'abord
villégier le rétablissement de l'ordre
public après les multiples nuit
d'émeutes on a connu en guadeloupe et
l'ouverture d'un débat sur une plus
large autonomie de la guadeloupe risque
de raviver les revendications dans ce
sens de plusieurs territoires français
qui veulent être autonomes ou
indépendants à tour deux raisons
[Musique]
d'après eux la guadeloupe pourrait mieux
se gérer elles mêmes il souhaite moins
d'égalité avec l'hexagone plus de
liberté de décision par les élus locaux
le gouvernement est prêt à en parler du
moment que ces débats certes à résoudre
les vrais problèmes
[Musique]
oh
vous venez de le voir à la corse dont
deux élus indépendantistes ' réclame un
débat similaire à celui de la guadeloupe
regardée
qu'en est il de la corse où nous ne
cessons d'amorcer le dialogue et de
faire part de nos revendications de
manière démocratique où nous travaillons
pour faire évoluer notre statut où les
nationalistes sont majoritaires l'état
ne peut plus nous ignorer femu a corsica
appelle une nouvelle fois l'état allait
dans le sens de l'histoire en installant
un processus politique nouveau en corse
tournant le dos aux vieux démons du
centralisme exacerbée voire d'une
attitude coloniale
une mentalité de guerre froide c'est ce
que dénonce moscou et pékin dans une
tribune conjointe de leur ambassadeur
aux états unis et cela concerne le
sommet virtuel pour à la démocratie
organisé par le président américain joe
biden les 9 et 10 décembre prochain les
détails avec à notre correspondante à
moscou maylis des stryges
dans une tribune conjointe publiée ce
vendredi dans la revue américaine the
national interest les ambassadeurs
chinois et russes à washington reproche
aux états unis d'exclure leurs pays du
sommet virtuel pour la démocratie que le
président joe biden organisera les 9 et
10 décembre prochain selon les armes
baladeur en s'arrogeant le droit de
définir qui est un pays démocratique et
qui n'est pas éligible à ce statut les
etats unis font preuve les mentalité de
guerre froide celle-ci ravivera je cite
la confrontation idéologique et les
fractures mondiale tout en créant de
nouvelles lignes de divisions
les diplomates rejette l'idée d'un
modèle unique de démocratie écoutez la
paix le développement l'équité la
justice la démocratie et la liberté sont
des valeurs communes de l'humanité la
démocratie n'est pas la prérogative dans
certains pays ou de groupes de pays
meyer droits universels de tous les
peuples il peut être concrétisé de
plusieurs façons nuls modèle ne peut
convenir à tous les pays le succès du
modèle emprunté par un pays dépend de sa
capacité à répondre aux réalités du pays
à suivre la tendance de l'époque et à
favoriser le développement économique la
stabilité sociale et le pro ainsi qu
assurer une vie meilleure pour la
population il ne faisant face à des
rappels les autres pays à respecter la
charte des nations unies à ne pas
s'ingérer dans les affaires intérieures
d'autres états sous prétexte de lutter
contre la corruption de promouvoir les
valeurs démocratiques ou encore de
protéger les droits humains il y a
suffisamment de guerres et de troubles
dans le monde pour prouver que la
propagation de la démocratie de son
système politique et de ses valeurs par
opposition à celle des autres pays
sapera gravement la paix la sécurité la
stabilité régionale et internationale
les bombardements de la yougoslavie les
interventions militaires en irak en
afghanistan et en libye et la
transformation démocratique ne font que
nuire il faudrait que les pays se
focalise sur la bonne gestion de leurs
propres affaires sans critiquer les
autres de manière condescendante d'une
besoin de s'inquiéter pour la démocratie
en russie et en chine certains
gouvernements étrangers ferait mieux de
penser à eux mêmes et à ce qui se passe
chez eux est ce la liberté qu'en divers
rassemblements dans leur pays sont
dispersées à coups de balles en
caoutchouc et de gaz lacrymogènes
cela ne ressemble pas beaucoup à la
liberté les ambassadeurs russes et
chinois font ainsi écho aux critiques
formulées à moscou et à pékin après
l'annonce le 23 novembre de la centaine
de pays conviés au sommet pour la
démocratie le porte parole du président
russe dmitri peskov avait ainsi déclaré
dès le lendemain que les états unis
préféreraient diviser les pays entre
ceux qui sont selon eux au bout et ceux
qui sont mauvais plutôt que de réduire
et supprimer les lignes de démarcation
en ethiopie les tensions restent vives
entre le gouvernement fédéral et les
rebelles du tigre est en déplacement
hier sur le front à le premier ministre
a appelé je cite à détruire la révolte
une déclaration qui survient après la
prise par les insurgés d'une ville
située à 220 km de la capitale addis
abeba pas ce qui inquiète la communauté
internationale envoie cela avec françois
disque et fitch
[Musique]
des chants patriotiques résonne dans les
rues d'addis abeba une cérémonie
organisée par les autorités éthiopiennes
afin de soutenir les troupes
gouvernementales qui combattent le front
de libération du tigre est depuis plus
d'un an parmi les participants des
personnalités du pays comme le
légendaire marathoniens et les
gebreselassie double médaillé d'or aux
jeux olympiques
je veux assurer aux tplf que je vais me
sacrifier défendre l'ethiopie
qui dit représenter le peuple tigréens
déstabilise notre pays au delà de sa
région
les rebelles qui gré 1 ont annoncé cette
semaine d'importants gains territoriaux
et affirment contrôler la ville de shewa
robeet à 220 km au nord-est de la
capitale
en réponse le premier ministre habib
ahmed s'est rendu sur le champ de
bataille pour une démonstration de force
salué par la population selon un média
d'état il dirige lui même la contre
offensive
l'ennemi n'a pas une posture qui peut
rivaliser avec la nôtre nous gagnerons
et nous allons laisser un pays libre et
prospère à nos enfants c'est ce que nous
sommes venus faire ici et les résultats
sont bons des victoires
pourtant démenti ce samedi par le porte
parole du front de libération du tigre
et leur présence à des bribes errani ou
cnra n'a pas créé la moindre brèche dans
la marche de nos forces vers la victoire
elle ne le fera jamais une escalade
supplémentaire dans un conflit qui
continue d'alarmé la communauté
internationale plusieurs états dont les
états unis si le royaume uni l'allemagne
l'italie la france ont appelé cette
semaine le ressortissant a quitté
l'ethiopie
vendredi le programme alimentaire
mondial annonce que la situation
humanitaire s'est encore détériorée au
tigré mais aussi en amara et en afar
selon l'organisation des nations unies
près de 9 millions et demi de personnes
souffrent de la faim dans ces trois
régions d'ethiopie
on a voté pour à la présidentielle au
honduras les bureaux de vote ont fermé à
17h heure locale à l'issue du scrutin
s'annonce serré à une favorite est tout
de même a donné par les sondages comme
haras à castro dirigeante du parti de
gauche libre mais en face l'héritier du
président sortant nasri à spirales n'a
pas dit son dernier mot dans un pays mis
en grande difficulté par la corruption
et où le taux de pauvreté ne cesse
d'augmenter les honduriens semble
vouloir opter pour le changement a les
précisions de walle bennani
elle est peut-être celle qui va tourner
la page d'un pays depuis douze ans sous
la férule des conservateurs les
partisans de 6 aux maracas trop leaders
partis de gauche libre et se concerte
avant des dernières heures important
nous sommes pratiquement orphelin de ce
que devrait être un véritable état nous
n'avons pas d'état de droit et c'est ce
que nous essayons de reprendre
aujourd'hui adultes jeunes hommes et
jeunes femmes appelés à voter pour
renverser les courbes d'une crise
économique migratoires et sanitaires
avec l'apparition de la pandémie le
chômage a presque doublé entre 2019 et
2020 en grimpant jusqu'à près de 11%
nous avons besoin d'une éducation
gratuite d'hôpitaux de médicaments
pétales
le prix du panier alimentaire de base
est trop élevé le salaire minimum est
trop bas
demacia les politiciens promettent et
promettent mais je ne vois rien je n'ai
jamais été soutenue par un politicien
le regard est donc tournée vers des
candidats à la présidentielle attendue
sur les dossiers du travail mais aussi
de la corruption et de la violence le
honduras pays considéré par beaucoup
comme un narco état et dans le taux
d'homicide est l'un des plus élevés au
monde
[Musique]
favori des sondages sur marat castro
souhaite mettre donc fin à la
criminalité qui gangrène le pays mais
également casser les codes d'un héritage
catholique et évangélique en se faisant
la porte drapeau du mariage homosexuel
ou encore de la légalisation de
l'avortement
c'est pour cela que nous avons besoin
d'une femme comme présidente de la
république
[Musique]
pour gérer les fonds avec transparence
et dire non à la corruption au honduras
la candidate castro épouse de l'ancien
président zelaya renversé par un coup
d'état militaire en 2009 cette dernière
est violemment critiqué par le chef
d'état et son parti conservateur qui la
présente comme une communiste juan
orlando hernandez qui est toujours dans
le collimateur de la communauté
internationale pour des allégations de
trafic de drogue et de fraudes aux
élections de 2010 huit
autres candidats dans la lumière et au
passé sulfureux iain me rosenthal le
leader du parti libéral de centre-droit
a promis un bon d'achat de 60 dollars
par mois à chaque adulte l'homme de 56
ans a été condamné en 2010 est à trois
ans de prison aux états unis pour
blanchiment d'argent une élection
scrutée de près par les observateurs
internationaux aient annoncé des plus
serrés
et pour terminer des réactions
l'afghanistan où la situation économique
reste plus que jamais incertaine après
l'arrivée au pouvoir des talibans l'été
dernier lé 20 années de présence des
troupes occidentales ont laissé des
traces et certains commerçants de la
capitale kaboul mise sur la revente
d'équipement en provenance à des bases
américaines pour tenter de survivre les
précisions sur place de notre envoyé
spécial antoine cléroux malgré le départ
des troupes américaines au mois d'août
dernier il reste encore des traces de
leur présence ici à kaboul comme par
exemple ces quelques magasins où l'on
trouve toutes sortes de choses en
provenance des bases américaines sur le
sol afghan vestes pantalons chaussures
casquettes sacs à dos mais aussi
jumelles couteau boussole sacs de
couchage de véritable caverne d'ali baba
ça vient de la base de bagram
sa date d'avant quand il y avait la
guerre et maintenant ça se vend c'est ce
que beaucoup de gens achètent
essentiellement pour la pêche et la
chasse et puis il y a des marchandises
qu'on achète pour faire des cadeaux des
t-shirts avec afghanistan marqué dessus
toutes sortes de choses qu'on offre en
cadeau principalement il existe aussi
quelques témoignages de la contribution
française à cette guerre en afghanistan
comme cet insigne bleu blanc rouge
ou encore ce porte clés aux couleurs de
la france et de la force internationale
d'assistance et de sécurité sous
commandement de l'otan dans certaines
épiceries on retrouve aussi de la
nourriture à l'origine destiné pour les
troupes us comme par exemple ces rations
de soldats ou encore plus surprenant
des queues de homard
depuis le temps les américains --pays si
chez nous c'est resté je ne sais pas
comment mais les gars les ont récupérés
à bagram et depuis on les vend il nous
les vendent et nous les mettons sur le
marché
mais depuis le départ définitif des
américains le filon se tarit
les affaires et bien on ne se plaint pas
mais bon ce n'est plus comme avant elle
la présence de ces bases us sur le sol
afghan générer toute une économie
parallèle qui disparaît donc peu à peu
en attendant il reste encore quelques
bonnes affaires à faire c'est la fin de
cette édition merci à vous de l'avoir si
l'on va se retrouver dans une trentaine
de minutes rester avec nous sur rtl
france acquis
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]